[Musik]
guten morgen und herzlich willkommen
syrien syrien ist zum inbegriff eines
menschenverachtenden krieges geworden
mit protesten auf der straße gegen die
verhaftung von jugendlichen gegen die
folter von jugendlichen hat alles
angefangen
das war vor sechs jahren daraus ist eine
volkserhebung gegen präsident baschar al
assad geworden dann ein bürgerkrieg und
jetzt ein krieg in dem internationale
mächte kräftig mitmischen den krisenherd
syrien hätten wir heute eine
spezialsendung zwei stunden hier in den
sternstunden
ich unterhalte mich mit kristin helberg
und wilfried buchta und danach übernimmt
meine kollegin barbara bleisch herzlich
willkommen auch von mir
ich stehe hier mitten in genf auf der
plastination vor dem hauptgebäude der
uno neben mir das kunstwerk brocken
es ist ein mahnmal für die opfer von
streubomben und von minen die person die
ich nachher gleich treffe kennt sich aus
mit kriegsopfern es ist der schweizer
jakob kern ist der länderdirektor des
uno welternährungsprogramms in syrien
und dort zuständig für die verteilung
der nahrungsmittel später dann spreche
ich im studio über die situation in
syrien über die zukunft in syrien und
vor allem auch über die verantwortung
der weltgemeinschaft angesichts der
kriegsgräuel zu gast bei mir im studio
unter anderem srf nahost-experte pascal
weber
bis gleich ja und wir geben jetzt hier
in der ersten stunde unserer
spezialsendung der frage nach welche
wurzeln der krieg in syrien in der
geschichte des landes hat und ob dieser
krieg auch ein religionskrieg ist
wir das sind die
politikwissenschaftlerin kristin helberg
sagt von 2001 bis 2008 in syrien gelebt
und von dort als journalistin vorwiegend
für deutschsprachige medien berichtet
heute lebt und arbeitet sie als autorin
und nahost expertin in berlin
wilfried buch da er ist
islamwissenschaftler er hat von 2005 bis
11 im irak gelebt und dort als
politischer berater für die uno mission
gearbeitet
er ist heute als buchautor und publizist
tätig war hellberg hat man es sehen
kommen hatten sie eine vorahnung was da
in syrien für eine katastrophe kommen
wird zunächst einmal war das was 2011
begann ein großer hoffnungsschimmer und
eine ja etwas was eigentlich sehr viel
mut und kraft ausgelöst hat auch in der
bevölkerung wenn man aber mit den
älteren oppositionellen im land
gesprochen
mit der generation der heute 60 70
jährigen die alle im gefängnis gesessen
hatten unter vater und sohn als er zum
teil dann haben die einen gewarnt und
haben gesagt diese revolution diese
proteste werden massiv unterdrückt
werden und es wird sehr blutig werden
die jungen leute diese generation die
sich getraut hat zu demonstrieren
die die 80er jahre nicht erlebt hatten
wo wir schon mal unterdrückung hat nun
repression durch die ssd haben den nicht
so genau zugehört und wollten das nicht
wahrhaben und ließen sich einfach
einstecken
von diesen arabischen frühling der
falsch betitelt wurde in den anderen
ländern tunesien ägypten etc
also von daher hatten sie beide
vorahnungen es könnte eine hoffnung drin
sein es könnte aber sehr fatal
ja und das war eben abzusehen für alle
diejenigen die das regime gut kannten
und die die foltergefängnisse kanten und
eben die zustände die willkür dieser
geheimdienste denen war klar es hat wird
sich nicht einfach entmachten lassen und
den preis den vor allem die zivilisten
in syrien jetzt dafür bezahlen
den sehen wir jetzt heute und in den
vergangenen zehn jahren sie sprechen das
jahr 2011 fahren damit hat begonnen mit
einer art proteste dann volkserhebungen
bürgerkrieg internationalisierte krieg
buch da wie konnte es soweit kommen zu
diesem desaster in syrien
naja das hat interner konflikt ursachen
die 2011 an die oberfläche traten denn
es hat ja schon seit jahren geehrt im
lande wie frau hellberg schon sagte das
regime der assad familie ist eben ein
schiitisches minderheiten regime der
alawitischen schiiten gruppe und die
opfer oder die unterlegenen dieser
gewaltherrschaft waren immer die
mitglieder der bevölkerungsmehrheit der
sunniten und die waren über jahre und
jahrzehnte hinweg an den rand gedrängt
politisch und wirtschaftlich
marginalisiert unterdrückt und es war
nur eine frage der zeit wenn sich
irgendein x bestimmte konflikt faktoren
häuften dass es da zu einem ausbruch von
gewalt kommt und dieser ausbruch von
gewalt war das war vorhersehbar eben
auch dann nicht mehr zu stoppen hat sie
nicht überrascht das hat mich nicht
überrascht weil ich ja schon situation
ähnlicher art im irak erlebt habe wo
eben die situation etwas anders war
dort herrschte eben nicht eine
schiitische bevölkerungsmehrheit sondern
eine sunnitische bevölkerungsminderheit
herrschte über jahrzehnte und das saddam
hussein über eine schiitische
bevölkerungsmehrheit und dann hat sich
das nach der us-invasion gedreht der
amerikaner haben die schiiten an die
macht gebracht durch demokratische wahl
aber die schiiten haben eben und die
gunst der stunde nicht genutzt und
demokratie eingeführt sowie der westen
und die amerikaner hofften sondern sie
haben diese mehrparteiendemokratie die
von schiitischen parteien dominiert war
ausgenutzt um die sunnitische
bevölkerungsminderheit jetzt so hart zu
unterdrücken wie es vorher unter saddam
hussein der fall war
würde ich aber jetzt gerne gleich mal
widersprechen weil das ist mir ein
bisschen zu einfach wir haben in syrien
jack ein analytisches minderheiten
regime tatsächlich haben die us
geherrscht und haben sämtliche
bevölkerungsteile auch die sunniten
voran das städtische bürgertum die
geschäftsleute die profitiert haben von
diesem regime mit eingebunden die
christlichen teile der bevölkerung das
prinzip der apachen herrschaft ist viel
mehr loyalität wer zu den assad steht
wer die herrschaft der als unterstützt
wurde gefördert
bekam geschäftliche die es politische
positionen wir haben bis heute auch
unter den führenden figuren des regimes
sunniten und christen
das heißt es ist nicht so einfach und es
gibt auch immer noch sehr viele arme
anbieten wer also profitiert hat von der
herrschaft der ersatz das war die
erweiterte verwandtschaft das waren
einige clans den küsten hinterland aber
nicht alle anbieten und nicht alle
sunniten waren unterdrückt im gegenteil
sehr viele sunniten gerade in den großen
städten die händler von damaskus und
aleppo hatten sich ganz gut arrangiert
ich bin gespannt auf den weiteren
verlauf des gesprächs man merkt schon es
ist sehr kompliziert sind fraktion es um
religiöse elemente im spiel haben dass
verschiedene fraktion vier gruppen im
islam genannt wir kommen darauf zu
sprechen wir haben uns aber vorgenommen
für den ersten teil mal in die
geschichte des landes zu schauen und
dieser konflikt dieser krieg hat wurzeln
in der geschichte dieses landes führen
und die gehen zurück unter anderem auf
die neuordnung des gesamten nahen ostens
nach dem ersten weltkrieg versuchten
sehen wir einen kurzen filmbeitrag
[Musik]
früher gab es hier keine grenzen fast
500 jahre lang war die arabische
halbinsel teil des osmanischen reichs
als ich während des ersten weltkrieges
dessen ende abzeichnete traten die
späteren europäischen siegermächte auf
den plan und teilten den nahen osten
unter sich auf frankreich bekäme den
südosten anatoliens sowie den größten
teil des heutigen syrien und den libanon
südlich davon erhielten großbritannien
sämtliche gebiete zwischen dem
mittelmeer und am persischen golf
alles tina jordanien und irak zusätzlich
sicherte der britische außenminister
james baker den zionisten die errichtung
einer nationalen heimstätte für das
jüdische volk in palästina zu dieser
geheime plan
das zeigt speaker abkommen wurde
beschlossen als der erste weltkrieg noch
im gang war bereits 1920 sei aber die
politische landkarte fast genauso aus
wie heute und aus heutiger sicht
bemerkenswert syrien war in sechs
staaten aufgeteilt
so hatten beispielsweise auch die drusen
und die alawiten zwei der religiösen
minderheiten ihren eigenen staat wie
kurden gingen vergessen ebenso israel
den jüdischen staat gab es damals noch
nicht
aber seit dessen gründung 1948 rannte
syrien immer wieder gegen israel an
die bilanz drei verlorene kriege und der
verlust der fruchtbaren golanhöhen die
israel 1967 besetzte und später
annektierte
grund genug propagandistisch aufzurüsten
mit dem gewehr zu schlafen ist auch für
syrische schulmädchen mode geworden und
in der schulpause werden stadtrat loccum
zu klappern
die kriegerischen handgriffe ein
gedrillt das regime ist längst der
freien schulen herr geworden hat die 325
privatschulen die mehrheitlich
religiösen gemeinschaften gehörten
verstaatlicht und die schulprogramme
gleichgeschaltet die mobilisierung der
schuljugend verschafft dem links
ballistischen regime einen wichtigen
rückhalt handelt es sich bei der
herrschenden alawitischen offiziers
gruppe doch um eine minderheit
die offiziers gruppe war teil der
baath-partei jener partei die auch im
nachbarland irak lange das sagen hatte
die baath-partei baute syrien in einem
säkularen sozialistischen staat um und
die sowjetunion wurde zum wichtigsten
handelspartner
1970 übernahm der vormalige
verteidigungsminister hafez al assad die
macht
immer im oktober seit nunmehr zehn
jahren wird in syrien offiziell gefeiert
das regime unter der führung des
präsidenten assad gedenkt des oktober
krieges von 1973 damals so lautet die
interpretation der syrer stellten die
araber im krieg gegen israel
ihre nationale würde wieder her
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die baath partei bezeichnet sich als
sozialistisch äußerlich gibt sie sich
gerne etwas martialisch und ihre jungen
aktivisten zeigen stimmgewaltig dass sie
präsident hafis assad als symbol einer
arabischen revolution betrachten der
sozialistischen rhetorik zum trotz
erinnerte damaskus in der 1980 er jahren
eher an eine westliche großstadt als an
den ostblock die stadt bohmte nicht
zuletzt dank investitionen aus den
golfstaaten und ein aufgeklärtes
bürgertum gab den ton an
das gefiel den muslimbrüdern gar nicht
bereits als assad an die macht gekommen
war
verunglimpften sie die alawiten als
feind gottes in der 1970 er jahren
verübten sunnitische extremisten immer
wieder anschläge auf vertreter
religiöser minderheiten 1982 eskalierte
die situation in der stadt hama ließ das
regime einen aufstand der muslimbrüder
brutal niederschlagen bilanz mehrere
zehntausend tote bilder gibt es davon
keine
am 10 juni 2000 starb hafez al assad
einen monat später wurde sein sohn
baschar al assad mit 97,2 9% zum
präsidenten der syrischen arabischen
republik gewählt
baschar entließ politische gefangene
literarische salons entstanden man
sprach vom damaszener frühling der durch
den besuch von papst johannes paul dem
zweiten gekrönt wurde das bild das
geblieben ist und zwar jeden syrer
geblieben ist ist das treffen von papst
johannes paul dem zweiten mit präsident
baschar und dieses ereignisses das
syrische volk sehr von wasser
eingenommen
und deshalb sind wir so enttäuscht
wirklich tief verletzt dass diese
hoffnung die war damals verkörpert
verschwunden ist ja bilder papst
johannes paul der zweite präsident
baschar assad
wir haben sie diese bilder in erinnerung
diesen papstbesuch damals in syrien war
helge ich bin ganz gut befreundet mit
dem jungen oder mit dem geschäftsmann
der den papst durch die umlagen moschee
geführt haben hat johannes paul war ja
in der omari-moschee weil dort ein grab
ist das angeblich den kopf von johannes
dem täufer beinhaltet das war der grund
warum der papst sich ausgerechnet die
milliarden moschee innerhalb des nahen
ostens oder moz eine sensation dass eine
option ist das erste mal in der
geschichte der menschheit dass ein papst
eine moschee betritt das war wirklich
historisch und wurde auch gefeiert durch
die bevölkerung hinweg das stimmt und es
war ein signal aber wir haben eben
gesehen dass diese hoffnungen die sich
mit maschaal als hat verbannten auf
einem missverständnis beruht weil alle
dachten da kommt der junge computer
begeisterte präsident der eine zeit lang
in england
rogan medizin studiert hatte
und dort auch seine zukünftige frau
kennengelernt hatte und würde das land
nun zum besseren verändern was warschau
das hat aber tat ist das eher syrien
modernisiert aber er reformierte es
nicht und das war das missverständnis
auch bei uns im westen
wir dachten erst angetreten das land zu
demokratisieren das war aber in
wirklichkeit niemand außer gab es gar
nicht wenn die hand zur diktatur oder
nein auf gar die wende war
wirtschaftliche öffnung neoliberalismus
pur
private banken ausländische investoren
diejenigen die geld hatten profitierten
enorm von dieser wirtschaftlichen
öffnung von baschar al assad aber
politisch blieb alles beim gleichen und
diese im film erwähnten literarischen
salons ist war der damals zehner
frühling das waren vielmehr politische
diskussionen in denen man die roten
linien ab tastete was durfte man sagen
was nicht die endeten alle mit
verhaftungen und mehrjährigen
haftstrafen derjenigen die sie
organisierten das heißt baschar al assad
hat gleich klargemacht politische reform
wird es mit ihm nicht geben
seine macht basierte ja auch auf den
sollen die sein vater ihm hinterlassen
im militär den geheimdiensten und der
partie dass man die gleichen leute
verbucht aber wir haben uns vorgenommen
ein blick auf die geschichte zu werfen
dieser filmbeitrag das auch gezeigt hat
wenn man diese karten vergleicht heute
und 1920 also unmittelbar nach dem
ersten weltkrieg
viel geändert hat sich nicht und fahren
was auffällt sind diese starren grenzen
die wie mit dem lineal mit dem maßstab
gezeichnet auf der karte wirken ja die
sind resultat von grenzziehungen die
bestimmte offiziere der französischen
und britischen kolonialmächte die dann
später mandats möchte wurden in syrien
und irak und jordanien dann 1916 bis
1923 auf großen landkarten gezogen haben
mit dem lineal ungeachtet jahrhunderte
lang bestehende beziehungen zwischen
verschiedenen völkern stemmen
konfessionen
da wurde einfach wurden die interessen
london und paris
voran vorangestellt und man hat
künstliche staaten geschaffen
diese künstlichen staaten und das wird
heute immer deutlicher sind damals schon
auf sehr am sehr fragilen zerbrechlichem
fundament gebaut worden
und als die dann in den 40er 50er jahren
in die unabhängigkeit entlassen wurden
nachdem sie jahrzehntelang unter mandat
herrschaft gewisse grundlagen der
demokratie aufgenommen hatten ja kam es
soweit das nach und nach eben
militärische und ein parteien eliten die
macht übernahm
die dann gewaltenteilung und rechtsstaat
menschenrechte in der hintergrund
schauen und sich zu diktaturen
entwickelten und dann ging es eben nur
solange gut solange das wirtschaftliche
wachstum so lange eben ein
heilsversprechen geliefert wurde von den
bars herrschaften in syrien und dem irak
und als das verblasste kamen dann
interne konflikt vater faktoren ins
spiel
dann wurden auf einmal auch ethnische
und konfessionelle unterschiede zu einem
konfliktfaktor der dann 2003 und 2011
mit dazu beigetragen hat diese konflikte
auszulösen
das über die ganze zeit gesagt diese von
außen an dieser region herangetragene
idee von nationalstaaten hat nicht
funktioniert also im hinblick auf den
irak kann ist dezidiert sagen irak wurde
seit entlassung in die unabhängigkeit
1933 bis 2003 mit purer brutaler gewalt
zusammengehalten wir haben also im
südirak hier in dieser gegend eine große
schiitische bevölkerungsmehrheit die
machen etwa 65 prozent der bevölkerung
aus das sind schiitische araber
dann haben wir im zentrum und im norden
haben wir eben sunnitischer araber und
dann haben wir im nordosten haben wir in
eine kurdische minderheit die nicht
arabisch spricht und immer nach
unabhängigkeit strebt und die sunniten
herrschten das waren eben die tragenden
elemente der militärdiktaturen und der
bars alleinherrschaft und das saddam
hussein und das ganze staatsgebilde
wurde mit gewalt zusammen gehalt
und es funktionierte halbwegs so lange
eben das wirtschaftswachstum florierte
solange diese staaten eben den menschen
noch heilsversprechen in puncto sozialer
modernisierung und wirtschaftlichen
fortschritt machen konnten
aber als das alles zerbrach dann war das
ende vorprogramm das heißt aber hier
geht eine ära die sehr weit vor 100
jahren begonnen hat heute endgültig zu
ende
in gewisser weise ja weil die staaten
sicher schon auf lesen doch syrien
zerfällt eigentlich vor unseren augen
das gleiche was ähnlich ja das ist
schluss hatte ist eigentlich ist es ja
wird ja erwähnt dieses abkommen von
sykes pico leute 116 das ist für die
syrer bis heute ein trauma seiner hose
unsere ressourcen bestimmen über die hre
stimmen und verkleinern den kulturraum
bilder ist scham so nennt sich große
syrien auf arabisch das waren eben
eigentlich diese ganzen staaten das
heutige libanon jordanien die türkei der
irak das gehört alles zu bilateralen
dieser kulturraum des großen syrien und
das wurde beschnitten die syrer hatten
das gefühl sie werden eigentlich
reduziert auf ein staatsgebiet das in
wahrheit viel größer sein müsste und es
spielten eben immer andere
zugehörigkeiten die entscheidende rolle
das heißt dieses nationalgefühl wie wir
das in europa kennen als bürger eines
einer republik losgelöst von bassist
ideologie oder arabischen nationalismus
oder islamischer oder was auch immer
existierte eigentlich in syrien nicht
wirklich und das alles dominieren die
die alles dominierende ideologie
das ist ein bisschen zu kurz gekommen
ist dieser arabische nationalismus
das ist das was religionsersatz vor sich
her getragen haben als letzte bastion
des großen arabischen nationalismus ein
großer staat von nordafrika bis irak
sozusagen dieser plan
davon hat man dann in der region
getreuen davon hat man die chance und
das war der deckel der darunter alle
religionen hat irgendwie miteinander
klarkommen dass und dann grundsätzlich
ob ich christa oder sonstwas sondern ich
war hauptsache aber zum leidwesen der
kurden sind die gab es ja auch zehn
prozent der saison boden und die lippen
natürlich unter diesen extremen
nationalismus und reagierten mit dem
eigenen kurdischen nationalismus der
immer stärker geworden ist ja es wird
mehrfach diese partei genannt das
vielleicht auch nicht klar
auch so eine art deckel über allem was
war denn
sozialismus jörg ddr die wir da
ehemalige der beringsee was es heißt ja
eigentlich wiedergeburt erweckung also
es ging darum es waren eigentlich ein
sozialistisches projekt das war
eigentlich ab zu beginn eine
massenbewegung der unterdrückten der
arbeiter der bauern die sich gegen die
oligarchen und die grossgrundbesitzer
erheben sollten also eine sehr
sozialistische grundidee
sie wurde unter anderem von einem
christen auch mitbegründet und as
interessieren interessante ist dass eben
dann sowohl in damaskus als auch in
bagdad konkurrierende flügel der baath
partei an die macht kam
weswegen sich herr assad und herr museen
sei damals sehr ihnen die vertragen
haben seine erzfeinde waren
sie haben also immer darüber gestritten
werde die große panarabische einheit von
dem persischen golf auch nicht ganz so
lange führen sollte
und beide beide hatten die gleiche
ideologie aber hatten verschiedene
vorstellungen wer eben dieses gesamte
stadt konstrukt leiten und unter welchen
vorzeichen regieren sollte also
spinnefeind die beiden ja das ist so die
großwetterlage jetzt wir hat man das
konkret aus gesehen so dieses leben in
syrien ebenso wie in der ehemaligen ddr
oder stellt es gibt ja es gibt einige
parallelen wann immer ich besucher
bekamen in den jahren damals die in der
ddr gelebt hatten fanden die manches
sehr befremdlich und wenn sie so ein
bisschen auch verunsichert weil sie sagt
das ist ja wie in der ddr vor allem die
allgegenwart des geheimdienstes war
glaube ich noch stärker ausgeprägt in
thüringen wo wir 17 verschiedene
geheimdienste haben die tatsächlich die
gesamte gesellschaft durchdringen
das heißt unter mir war eine schule
haben der immer zufällig so zuverlässig
dem geheimdienst auch berichtete wo ich
gerade bin wenig von dem ich gerade
besuch hatte zum beispiel aus dem
ausland auf die ausländerinnen hat das
ja aber es geht jedes viertel hat seine
zuständigen spitze die kennen sich aus
und wenn ich vorgeladen werde als
syrischer journalist dann kann ich zwar
nicht hingehen werde ich abgeholt macht
also ich muss hingehen ich muss
irgendwas erzählen ich muss in gewisser
weise mitmachen das heißt es ist
wirklich eine gesellschaft die
durchsetzt ist und durchzogen von diesen
geheimdiensten die eine große willkür
ausüben das heißt d'azur laufe ich
ständig gefahr dass meine existenz
zerstört wird dass ein geheimdienst
mensch das passt wenn ich was du gesagt
hast das fast nicht was dein sohn an der
universität
sagt er hat sich angelegt mit dem sohn
eines generals der wirt exmatrikuliert
von heute auf morgen bin ich
ausgeliefert und immer bedroht in meiner
existenz und das hat syrien zu einem
jahr zum königreich des schweigens
gemacht sondern dass experten auf das
heißt man hat den kopf eingezogen man
hat sich weggeduckt und hat möglichst
sich unpolitisch gegeben und man war
recht gut versorgt durch hasler sagt der
hat seinem seiner bevölkerung einen deal
angeboten der gesellschaftsvertrag
lautete ich versorge ich versorge euch
und ihr haltet den mund die schilderung
können auch aus dem irak seien also so
eine ähnliche situation hatten wir auch
im irak irak galt in der ära von saddam
hussein als republik der angst republic
auf vierten und nicht war zum ersten mal
1991 damit einem schweizer fernsehteam
von 10 vor 10 mit christoph biller dann
hatten wir einen monat lang reportagen
gemacht aus dem irak direkt nach dem ko
weltkrieg der start war geschlagen
das regime war besiegt aber es ist nicht
kollabiert und damals wurden wir dann
begleitet von begleitern des irakischen
informationsministeriums die uns auf
schritt und tritt verfolgte und uns
quasi unsere versuchten unserer schritte
zu lenken und auch in unserer
berichterstattung sozusagen
einzuschränken und wir hatten dort
faszinierende tiefe einblicke in dieses
wirken und werken des irakischen
geheimdienstes alle leute denen wir
damals auf der straße begegneten liefen
erst mal weg die hatten angst weil sie
fürchteten irgend ein falsches wort zu
sagen und das hätte ihn buchstäblich den
kopf kosten können und wir sind dann
später auch nach nord irak gebracht
worden in der nähe von kirkuk wo kurz
zuvor eben einen kurden aufstand
niedergeschlagen wurde und dort hat man
uns dann massengräber gezeigt von
angeblichen bei angehörigen die durch
kurdische aufständischen gruppen getötet
worden sein
das waren aber eben alles leichen die
man aus der erde holt die kurdische
kämpfer kleidung trugen die kleidung der
peschmerga und wir haben uns dann als
schweizer fan sind vor allem herr
christoph müller hat sich da sehr
energisch gegen verwehrt uns wurde eben
aufgetragen zu sagen das seien jetzt
alles was parteiangehörige
und das haben wir dann in unsere
berichterstattung nicht wiedergegeben
sondern gesagt es waren wahrscheinlich
kurdischer aufständische unter nacht
wurden wird des landes verwiesen also
propaganda bis in den letzten winkel
aber zurück zu syrien 2011 bei diesen
ersten aufrufen zu demonstrationen im
februar
los ging es im märz waren sie in
damaskus damals wenn ich richtig war
einen monat bevor es losging in damaskus
und traf eben auch soda sowie arabische
frühling in anderen ländern
also ich war in damaskus da trat gerade
mubarak in ägypten zurück
das war unglaublich leute starten mit
offenem mund auf die fernseh und hat
gesagt wenn die fahrer geht der pharao
dann ist alles möglich im nahen osten
geschieht diese situationen ganz unserer
sendung genau wollte haben dass das
schiefgeht und das interessante ist
eigentlich dass die älteren
oppositionelle michel kilo ist ein
bekannter christliche oppositioneller in
regime-gegner viele jahre an und gibt im
gefängnis gewesen den habe ich damals
getroffen er hat gesagt das dauert hier
noch wir brauchen noch mindestens ein
jahr das wird nicht so schnell gehen und
einen monat später ging es los das
bedeutet die etablierten eher links
säkularen oppositionellen haben das gar
nicht erkannt
in welchem zustand die jugendlichen
waren und die straße war und auch wie
groß die unzufriedenheit war und wie
groß der mut dann auch doch wurde
dagegen vorzugehen
die hatten ja dann ein lokales ereignis
in der südstadt da damit den
schulkindern die gefoltert wurden das
war der auslöser lokal für die ersten
proteste und in syrien hat sich das gros
gebreitet als eine revolution der
peripherie das heißt all die gebiete die
unter baschar al assad verloren hatte
denen es schlecht geht
die abgehängt waren durch seine
neoliberale politik die in damaskus zu
schicken cafés und moderne modeketten
geführt hatten
diese abgehängten menschen hatten nichts
mehr zu verlieren haben gesagt warum
soll ich mir doch klein machen wenn ihr
mich nicht mal mehr versorgt und ich
habe einen zweiten job gesuchten dritten
job ich weiß nicht wie ich meine kinder
groß werden soll
das waren die leute das ist im grunde
den nährboden den wasch al assad selbst
gelegt hatte in diesen zehn jahren
seiner herrschaft durch diese
wirtschaftspolitik die unzufriedenheit
die entstand und den
gesellschaftsvertrag seines vaters er
auf kündigte in dem er die leute nicht
mehr sozialistisch versorgte alle gleich
sondern diese großen unterschiede
der abstand wird niedergeschlagen ein
bürgerkrieg bricht aus wenn wir heute
auf syrien schaden habe ich den eindruck
man mal wir schon hin und schauen
gleichzeitig weg weil ich es ist so
kompliziert wie es ist so
unübersichtlich und gleichwohl so brutal
sie haben ja die menschen dort
kennengelernt vor ort in libyen hat die
internationale gemeinschaft interveniert
warum wir nicht ja also die amerikaner
haben sich bewusst aus dem aktiven
militärischen engagement in libyen
heraus gehalten weil sie diese
abschreckenden beispiele irak und
afghanistan hatten
also hat sie waren ja in ihrer aktien
sollten dort die demokratie verkaufen
nämlich mal an
sie haben die uno mission unterstützt
2003 sind die briten die amerikaner
einmarschiert ich mir für man sagen das
ist gründlich schiefgelaufen aus
heutiger sicht
das erläutert dass die bisher amerikaner
weil ja schauen sie sich mal an was wäre
wenn sie wenn du jetzt bilanz ziehen die
amerikaner waren neuneinhalb jahre im
irak sind 2011 abgezogen
sie haben einen blutzoll von 400.000
gefallenen soldaten entrichtet 30.000
amerikanische soldaten sind schwerst
behindert 60.000 amerikanische soldaten
sind posttraumatische belastet durch
posttraumatische belastungssyndrom
vergessen sie nicht die irakischen opfer
und ja sie haben wir haben 140.000
irakische zivilisten die in diesen
neuneinhalb jahren gestorben sind und
die amerikaner ein offizieller seite
mitgeteilt dass sie 880 milliarden us
dollar investiert haben
in den wiederaufbau des irak inoffiziell
es gibt stimmen der weltbank und
verschiedenen us-universitäten die sagen
die rechnung ist falsch es mindestens
2500 bis 3000 milliarden us dollar
und ich war dort sechs jahre aktiv und
ich sage ihnen das ergebnis ist kläglich
man hat demokratische institutionen
etabliert die aber inhaltsleer sind die
ihre funktion nicht erfüllen
das heißt wir haben demokratische wahlen
alle vier jahre wird ein parlament
gewählt
es gibt auch eine breite zahl von
parteien die aktiv sind
aber letztendlich gewinnen immer die
blogger der sich zusammenschließen
schiiten koalition zu einer super-show
koalition die dann eben die anderen
teilweise mit kollaborierenden gruppen
einbinden
aber eben meisten teilten die sunniten
ausschließen
und das hat dazu geführt dass die
sunniten die 2003 die schalthebel der
macht verloren haben in der bar sparte
unter saddam hussein waren sie führen
sie waren führend im militär den
geheimdienst sie haben diese
schaltzentralen verloren konnten nicht
wieder fuß fassen und sind sozial und
wirtschaftlich aneinander gedrängt
worden und das hat den nährboden gegeben
für machtvakuums die entstanden sind die
machtvakuum sind gefüllt worden
durch für ethische sunnitischer milizen
und vor allem durch den vorgänger des
tsv rain irak und dieser nährboden war
fruchtbar und aus diesem nährboden
heraus ist der bürgerkrieg 2006 bis 2008
entstanden und bis heute nähert sich der
es von diesen machtvakuums die
amerikaner geschaffen haben die nicht
gefüllt wurden spannend oder dieser es
denn für uns von außen beobachtenden der
einfach da plötzlich auf dieser
landkarte erschienen ist irgendwann eine
art staat versucht hat zu gründen
sie erklären jetzt wo die wurzeln dafür
liegen nur kurz jetzt zurück also sie
übertragen diese situation jetzt auf
syrien sie kommen in ihrem buch die
strenggläubigen fundamentalismus und
zukunft der islamischen welt zum schluss
militärinterventionen westlicher staaten
können bestehende übel nicht beseitigen
sondern nur verschlimmern
das ist meine praktische erfahrung aus
sechs jahren arbeit ich war fast täglich
im irakischen parlament
ich hatte mehrmals die woche eben reisen
von der bak der grünen zone die halbwegs
gesichert war
in die back da rats und die rote zone wo
permanent bürgerkrieg herrschte ich war
mehrmals im monat mit hubschrauber
einsetzen und mit us panzern unterwegs
im südirak und ich kann ihnen sagen die
amerikaner konnten durch ihre große
militärische übermacht zwar jeden gegner
der sich in offener feldschlacht ihnen
entgegenstellten
siegen aber sie in diesem häuser gewirr
von bagdad einer sechs millionen stadt
oder in den endlosen weiten dieser
sanddünen des süd iraks da können sie
keinen gegner stellen der entzieht sich
das ist asymmetrische kriegsführung das
ist david gegen goliath und im genommen
hatten die amerikaner zu wenig soldaten
sie haben trotz ihres großen
finanziellen mittel einsatzes immer noch
zu wenig ressourcen gehabt und vor allem
es gab einen unfrieden zwischen sunniten
und schiiten der durch den wegfall des
saddam husseins diktatorischem system
entstanden dass sie bekannte noch mal
warum nicht intervenieren weil das ist
eine frage die sich viele menschen
stellen oder macht da keiner weiß warum
geht dann nicht einmal rein
sie sagen ja in ihrem buch brennpunkt
syrien frau hellberg wie so oft nee das
war die falsche stelle also ich sage vor
allem dass diese ganzen westlichen
intervention eine katastrophe waren ja
aber sie sagen auch stromfresser in
ihrem kampf gegen assad und al qaida
aufzurüsten beklagt man in washington
und brüssel ihren machtverlust im land
genau die westlichen aus politik der
letzten jahrzehnte ist eine
aneinanderreihung von fehlentscheidungen
doppelmoral und katastrophen die mündete
in dem einmarsch im irak
völkerrechtswidrig auf lügen gebaut die
geburtsstunde el kaida im irak wir haben
es gehört heute sind die dr dissen
konnten sich ausbreiten nach syrien die
syrer bezahlen den preis für diese
verfehlte politik denn was wir hier
gesehen haben ist dass nach diesen
jahren von george hw bush im weissen
haus herr obama gewählt wurde der gesagt
hat ich hole amerikanische soldaten nach
hause
ich will kein abenteuer mehr ich will
mich hier nirgendwo mehr engagieren
dann haben wir sie an serbien libyen wo
eine nato intervention zustande kam weil
russland sich enthalten hat
freundlicherweise im weltsicherheitsrat
damals ging es angeblich um die
schutzverantwortung responsibility to
protect den schutz von zivilisten weil
eventuell gaddafi angestarrt
bombardieren könnte was hat die nato
gemacht sie ist nach libyen geflogen und
hat ghadhafi gestürzt
überdehnt das mandat nächster fehler
moskau hat gesagt so nicht mehr
der weltsicherheitsrat ist nicht dazu da
unliebsame regime zu stürzen aber sie
sagen sich ehrenmal events syrien
sein argument jetzt kommen ein argument
das heißt syrien ist aus meiner sicht
das einzige land in dem der schutz von
zivilisten mehr engagement gefordert
hätte ich fordere weniger bomben
fusionieren nicht mehr ob man schauen
sie der himmel über syrien ist voller
kampfjets jeder fliegt dort die
weltsicherheitsrat mitglieder fliegen
dort internationalem echte fliegen dort
die 1 gegen den as die anderen gegen die
aktivisten die dritten gegen die
hektische gruppen die vierten gegen die
gemäßigte rebellengruppen jeder fliegt
in syrien und bombardiert wer stirbt die
zivilisten wir brauchen weniger bomben
das heißt mein appell ist für eine
schutzzone was ich möchte ist mehr
engagement womöglich ein internationales
militärisches engagement das alleine und
ausschließlich dem schutz von zivilisten
dient nicht dem sturz vom regime für
irgendwelche nationalen interessen
sondern wirklich im sinne eines schutzes
von zivilisten und wo wenn nicht in
syrien wäre das dringend angesagt also
um diese situation zu befrieden die wir
hier sehen nicht so fragen sich mehr
jungen hier baut mars hat beck sondern
wirklich im sinne von wir verhindern die
bombardierung von zivilisten ob
durchlass hat russland die usa oder wen
auch immer ich möchte da noch etwas
hinzufügen
also die beispiele irak und afghanistan
beweisen dass selbst durch eine große
militärmacht wie die usa und das sind
die militärisch stärksten kräfte der
welt ein staat der aus widerstrebenden
bevölkerungsgruppen besteht die nicht
friedlich miteinander leben können und
wollen nicht durch gewalt zusammen
gehalten werden kann
und das beispiel libyen hat ja wieder
bewiesen 2011 dass diese kurzzeitige
militärintervention der amerikaner ja
sich ins gegenteil verkehrt hat gaddafi
ist gestürzt worden es gab keinen
kontrollierten regulären machtübergang
sondern es brach ein bürgerkrieg aus
chaos war entfesselt worden
und die hatten haben sich dort breit
gemacht und heute haben wir drei
regierungen
die gegeneinander kämpfen plus den es
mit seiner filiale
das ist kein argument so sagen wir
schützen keine zivilisten in syrien weil
herr buchner im nord irak hat das mal
sehr gut funktioniert in den 90er jahren
die schutzzonen die international
verhängt wurden ja aber ich es ist ein
für ein begrenztes territorium wenn man
einen will man einen einen stadtführer
und sein ganzes regime wegputzt weg
es geht nicht um wegrutschen sondern es
geht um einen bestimmten teil nämlich
im norden syriens im süden syriens und
durch die opposition kontrolliert 2011
mit dass drei teilen oder norden wie sie
es ansprechen die kurdengebiete dann
dass ihr es geliebt weiß chauffiert und
dann das dass das unter referenzsatz der
der nato ist überdehnt worden das uno
mandat und es ist alles aus dem ruder
gelaufen und ich weiß es wenn man eben
vor ort ist und solche dinge an stößt
dann entwickelt sich das in einer
eigendynamik die vorher sehr sehr schwer
vorher kalkulierbar und vorhersehbar ist
und aus all diesen gründen hat herr
obama wahrscheinlich 2013 darauf
verzichtet diese roten linien daneben
auch mit sanktionen zu bewahren wo ist
im hieß wenn herr assad giftgas
einsetzen werden die amerikaner
militärisch interveniert was steht denn
verlage gewarnt
was schlagen sie vor also ich persönlich
bin sehr abgeneigt gegen militärische
intervention weil ich das aus meiner
eigenen erfahrung erlebt habe das ist
das eigentliche kontraproduktiv was
hilft also die hände ja schon der
welches schon der internet westen kann
generell am besten nur helfen dort mit
humanitärer hilfe für die flüchtlinge
und da muss man eben auch sehr
konsequent und sehr hart sei gegenüber
allen konfliktparteien und nicht mit
zweierlei maß messen und diese dinge
dann eben auch durchsetzen mit
uno-mandat und mit einer uno resolution
im sicherheitsrat darüber muss hart
gestritten und verhandelt werden wir
haben ja einige uno-resolutionen die
genau das besagen dass die vereinten
nationen über grenzen hinweg über
konfliktlinien hinweg helfen dürfen es
funktioniert trotzdem nicht optimal und
wir haben ja sogar einen politischen
verhandlungsprozess in genf regelmäßig
oder jetzt auch in astana wo man sich
trifft wo also die konfliktparteien
vermeintlich sich zusammensetzen um eine
lösung zu gesprächen unter anleitung von
stars davon dem ist oder dem uno
sondergesandten
aber das ist im grunde die vortäuschung
eines diplomatischen prozesses der in
der realität gar nicht stattfinden kann
weil die machtverhältnisse im land ganz
andere sind wir haben so lange keine
politische lösung wie nicht alle
konfliktparteien überzeugt sind dass
kämpfen keinen sinn mehr macht
das hat regime hat zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt überhaupt keinen grund
aufzuhören zu kämpfen weil es mit der
unterstützung russlands und des irans
vor allem militärisch fakten erzeugt am
boden und deswegen nach genf erd- und
sagt wir sind wieder da aber wir haben
kein interesse irgendwie macht abzugeben
und dann kommen auch die internationalen
mächte dazu die hier auch noch ja ich
denke man muss auch immer darauf
hinweisen dass immer gesagt wird die uno
könne sehr viel tun und sehr viel
bewirken genau es im zweiten teil an
unserer sendung das thema und dort auch
eben die ganzen hilfen die international
da bereits laufen wir uns vorgenommen
auch und eingangs schon angesprochen die
religiöse situation im land anzuschauen
vor dem krieg waren ungefähr zehn
prozent der bevölkerung christen eines
der zentren des religiösen lebens war
das kloster muss sagt sie sehen wir
einen kurzen filmbeitrag
[Musik]
auf einem felsvorsprung am rande eines
schmalen teils befindet sich mal muss
das kloster des heiligen moses von abc
gegründet wurde es vor 1500 jahren durch
eine gruppe frommer männer die sich in
die abgeschiedenheit zurückzog um ein
asketisches leben zu führen das kloster
geriet im siebzehnten jahrhundert in
vergessenheit und wurde erst 1982 vom
italienischen jesuiten pater paul oder
loriot zu neuem leben erweckt seit 1991
mit dabei
der syrer jacques muller was mar musa
außergewöhnlich machte warm zwei dinge
erstens dass wir jedem eine tasse tee
sehr wirken der uns besuchte und
zweitens erklärten wir den besuchern die
fresken des klosters und die geschichte
des ortes vor allem die muslime
dürsteten danach das christentum
kennenzulernen
[Musik]
mar musa war ein ort des dialogs der
sinnsuchende aus europa genauso
empfehlen wie die leute aus dem
nachbardorf die fast zu 100 prozent
muslime waren
[Musik]
unser erstes ziel ist das gebet das
zweite ziel ist etwas mit den händen zu
erschaffen und unser drittes ziel ist
die gastfreundschaft in diesem sinne ein
amerikanisches willkommen wir haben auch
noch ein viertes ziel nämlich den dialog
und das friedliche zusammenleben mit
unseren muslimischen brüdern
dies sind bilder die man heute nicht
mehr machen kann
nach sechs jahren bürgerkrieg ist die
krone auf wenige mitglieder geschrumpft
sagt murats lebt im irak und vom gründer
musas paolo dal olio fehlt seit seiner
entführung vor fast vier jahren jede
spur
in einer welt zu leben die sich nicht um
zusammenarbeit solidarität und den
dialog kümmert interessiert mich nicht
der glaube der orientalischen christen
ist verwurzelt in der geschichte dieser
region
wir sind die söhne einer kirche von
märtyrern einer kirche die nach wie vor
das martyrium fliegt aber heute sind es
nicht nur wir die christen die verfolgt
werden
bis vor 100 jahren im osmanischen reich
geschah als die armenier und die
syrischen christen massakriert wurden
heute werden leider alle syrer
gleichermaßen verfolgt beurteilt und
massakriert
wir alle sind opfer mit ihm ja der
jesuit bartoli bis heute verschollen von
iris verschleppt was geht in ihnen vor
wenn sie diese bilder sind sie kennen
den ort ich kenne denn auch das war der
erste ort zu dem ich gereist wenn für
ein langes radiofeature damals das war
mein auftrag mit dem ich 2001 nach
syrien gegangen bin deswegen trifft
möchte schon ihn zu treffen aber ein
sehr beeindruckender pater abonnenten in
die leute in die gemeinschaft vor ort
und seine geschichte ist auch
interessant gerade was das verhältnis
der religionen betrifft oder auch den
umgang des regimes mit den religionen
betrifft den arboner paula hatte sich ja
über jahrzehnte eingesetzt für diesen
dialog zwischen muslimen und christen
der aufstand begann er hatte nichts mit
religion zu tun unter den
demonstrierenden christen wie anbieten
wie alle möglichen mitglieder auch von
minderheiten und basische habe war ein
junger christlicher filmemacher der in
homs ermordet wurde durch einen
scharfschützen des regimes und die
kirche in damaskus verwertete seine
beerdigung weil die dortigen bischöfe
und offiziellen kirchenvertreter zum
regime halten müssen aus bestimmten
gründen
das heißt um die beerdigung dieses
jungen mannes zu ermöglichen hat pater
paul die jungen leute nach der mutter
eingeladen in dieses kloster um ihn dort
zu bestatten und ihm die letzte würde zu
erweisen
daraufhin musste er das land verlassen
das regime hatte paolo ausgewiesen
soviel zum schutz der christen durch das
syrische regime wer pro assad ist darf
bleiben egal ob sony oder christ oder
allagui wer dieses regime in frage
stellt wer in irgendeiner weise die
herrschaft der assad anzweifelt wird
verhaftet gefoltert getötet haben die
download zu sagen jetzt schon wir haben
es hier nicht mit deinem religions-
kommt nicht primär zu ungenau
ursprüngliche ursprünglich ein
machtkonflikt es geht um die religion
trends kommen genau ja dann möchte ich
zu sagen da hat frau hellberg recht
ursprünglich war es kein religiöser
konfessioneller konflikt nur hat das
assad regime
auf so einer schmalen unterstützer
grundlage regiert dass es dann beim
ausbruch dieser proteste irgendwann die
konfessionelle religiöse karte gezogen
hat und hat dann gesagt
wir vereinnahmen jetzt die religiösen
minderheiten die für uns sind das sind
vor allem die christen das sind die
drusen das sind bestimmte schiitischen
minderheiten für uns wir vereinnahmen
die für unsere sache wir privilegieren
sie gegen die sunnitische mehrheit und
gegen all die abweichler aus anderen
religiösen gruppen die gegen uns sind
also sprechen von der dann version allen
karl dann würde das polarisiert und dann
wurde der konflikt immer stärker
konfession alliierten so dass heute doch
im großen und ganzen da die konflikt
komponente doch religiös konfessionell
ist es gibt einen radiobeitrag noch dazu
ein schweizer priester der eben die
menschen in syrien besucht hat mehr
monate dort war kann man auf der online
jetzt sich anhören dann auch einen
artikel über alfredo eine schweizerin
mit syrischen wurzeln
sie sagt ein großer teil der christen
unterstützt bis heute den syrischen
präsidenten baschar al assad der selbst
einer religiösen minderheit angehört sie
glauben dass nur er sie als minderheit
weiterhin schützen kann genau trügerisch
baschar assad beschützt nicht die
minderheiten er benutzt sie für seine
persönlichen machterhalt wer sich als
christlicher würdenträger bis heute
hinter einem regime stellt das
kriegsverbrechen und verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit in einem solchen
ausmaß begeht bringt er die mitglieder
der eigenen gemeinschaft in große gefahr
und das müssen wir immer mit bedenken
wenn wir mit bischöfen mit materialien
aus syrien zu tun haben auch mit dem
mufti denn jede offizielle funktion
ob ein religiöser würdenträger ob ein
der chef einer oper ob der chef einer
institution wie eine universität die
industrie und handelskammer die
frauen-union wer eine offizielle
position hat in syrien ist vom regime
abgesegnet und fungiert in gewisser
weise als indirekter sprecher auch
dieses regimes das müssen wir mit
bedenken wenn die offizielle
kirchenvertreter hören aus syrien die
natürlich in großer not sind auch weil
sie einerseits ihre gemeinden schützen
wollen die sie aber eben womöglich nicht
schützen indem sie sich eindeutig hinter
assad stellen weil sie dann erst recht
zum angriffsziel
wir müssen uns noch mal konkret angucken
sie haben das sehr schön beschrieben
also der fw an einnahmen die
minderheiten wie ist das praktisch
passiert ab 2012 schon vorher wurden
diese alawiten alawitische schabiha
milizen das sind die geister also hat
dies schon in den jahrzehnten zuvor auch
gab wurden losgeschickt und haben
brutale massaker begangen
gegen sunnitische dörfer im umland von
homs daraufhin kam ein rascher gefühl
auf unter den sunniten sunnitische
wohngebiete wurden kollektiv bestraft
mit abregelung mit aus hunger mit
bombardieren das heißt man hat die
suiten kollektiv bestraft und bei ihnen
ein gefühl von rache zu erzeugen
mit dem man dann als präsident assad
sagen konnte seht her liebe minderheiten
die sunniten wollen euch alle an den
kragen
die wollen alle rache und ihr werdet
nicht sicher sein in einem zukünftigen
übrigen ist das hat das von einem meter
konfessionell taut wir haben die dann
menschenrechtsverletzung gab es auch auf
der anderen seite bei den rebellen auch
auf der seite des ist es das was sie mit
konfessioneller kann man auch zwischen
den schiiten und sunniten also unter der
muss lesen sehen sie die die
zugehörigkeit zu einer konfessionellen
gruppe ist ein machtpotenzial und
hardliner extremisten sowohl
unterschieden wie sunniten benutzen
dieses macht potenzial um durch
bestimmte gewalttaten die eigene gruppe
um sich zu scharen
denn wenn man opfer von fremden
gewalttaten haben wir mal
wir haben jetzt einen schiitischen
milizen führer der bewacht jetzt oder
beschützt ein großes stadtviertel im
osten von bagdad mendes city
dort gibt es dann regelmäßig große
sunnitische terroranschläge des
realistischen es dann werden diese
schiitischen bewohner des viertels
natürlich schutz suchen bei den
schiitischen milizen diese milizen sagen
wieder wir müssen einen totalen
konfrontation krieg führen gegen die
sunniten und nicht unterscheiden
zwischen guten und schlechten sunniten
sondern die sind alle unsere feinde
umgekehrt machen die sunniten das
gleiche das heißt extremisten auf beiden
seiten nutzen die konfessionelle karte
um ihre eigene klientel an sich zu
binden
ungeachtet der negativen folgen die das
wird staatlichen zusammenhalt und für
den zusammenhalt von staat gesellschaft
und dem land überhaupt bewirkt das ist
ja interessant
hatte sagt murat hat ja selbst gesagt
wir sind alle opfer was meint er damit
auch die muslime dieser region sind
opfer des s denn der sogenannte
islamische staat hat ja eine sehr
radikale auslegung des islam der all
jene die dann nicht konform gehen und
die eben weiter ihre wasserpfeife oder
ihre zigarette rauchen wollen um musik
hören wollen und das wollen die syrer
und iraker alle gerne weitermachen
bestraft so das heißt die hauptopfer
dieses radikalen islamistischen terrors
sind sunniten in der region das müssen
wir uns auch klar machen weil wir ja
schnell dazu neigen nur die minderheiten
zu sehen wie sie verfolgt werden
unterdrückt werden und das sorgt gerade
unter syrern für einen großen frust weil
die hauptopfer dieses ganzen 6 jährigen
krieges bisher sind vor allem unter
sunniten zu finden und deswegen sagt er
auch ganz klar wir sind alle opfern wir
sollten uns nicht instrumentalisieren
lassen mit dem der ist eigentlich mehr
opfer und für wen ist es gefährlicher
und was wird später passieren was
passiert jetzt nicht dem massaker sehen
wir jetzt warum sollten wir aus angst
vor massa controller bieten in der
zukunft die man verhindern muss
natürlich aber warum sollten wir angst
davor jetzt mit einem regime
zusammenarbeiten das konkret massaker
begeht wöchentlich an verschiedenen
bevölkerungsteilen in diesem land also
was ich damit sagen will die islamische
oder konfessionelle karte ist leicht
instrumentalisieren
für bestimmte zwecke und irgendwann
nimmt es dann eine dynamik an die sich
schwer aufhalten und zurückdrehen lässt
also jetzt ist so viel blut vergossen
das sehr sehr viele schiiten im irak
beispielsweise nicht mehr mit sunniten
zusammen leben wollen und wie zur werse
umgekehrt genau der gleiche fall das
heißt moderate stimmen aus sunnitischen
und schiitischen lagern haben es schwer
sich gegen die hardliner durchzusetzen
denn die können immer wieder darauf
verweisen schaut mal da gibt es
permanent übergriffe der gegnerischen
seite auf unser lager die einzige
hoffnung besteht darin konfessionell
reine wohn und siedlungsgebiete zu haben
und der territorium abzusichern und die
anderen auszugrenzen und zu unterdrücken
denn die anderen sind der feind und das
ist eine dynamik die eben seit jahren im
irak zu verfolgen es seit 2003
und seit 2011 leider auch in syrien
wir haben in syrien jetzt vor allem die
ganz gezielte demografische
veränderungen
sich das regime bemüht indem eben
bestimmte gebiete abgeregelt werden
ausgehungert werden
demand nicht die menschen aufgeben das
sehen wir den letzten tagen vor allem
die jüngste entwicklung wie es so oft da
costa lag das hat jeder mitbekommt genau
vom land das immer noch so seine
schulden noch genau dass sie in den
kommissionen oder eben die verschiedenen
islamischen bereiche spielen eine rolle
in der wobei das regime bemüht sich eben
darum die ursprünglichen
bevölkerungsgruppen zu vertreiben die
werden gerade alle in den norden in die
provinz idlib geschickt die noch unter
oppositions herrschaft steht und bemüht
sich dann dort assad loyale menschen
anzusiedeln vor allem schiiten nach
möglichkeit von dem es übrigens nur sehr
wenige gibt in syrien
das betrifft eben vor allem das
grenzgebiet zum libanon weil dort ja die
schiitische hisbollah wirkt ein enger
verbündeter des iran
und deswegen soll dieses ganze gebiet in
der nähe der küste und des libanon
führte
dunkelrot schafft genau wie soll von
allen kräften besiedelt werden und dass
es eine form von politischer säuberung
weil assad gegner werden verjagt und es
ist in manchen teilen zugleich eine
konfessionelle säuberung weil so nieten
vertrieben werden und schäden gezielt
eingesetzt also von beiden soll dann
machen wir die kurdischen
einflussgebiete unternehmens spaziert
das einflussgebiet dessert es
kompliziert wird ja noch weil die
schiiten eine schutzmacht haben in iran
und die sunniten mit saudi arabien haben
wir die internationale verflechtung
das ist also das ist ein exempel par
excellence in syrien ist eben das
assad-regime auf gedeih und verderb
abhängig von zwei externen großen
mächten die dort sich einmischen das
eine ist russland russland hat 2015 sein
militärisches engagement hochgefahren
hat mit luftwaffen unterstützung eben
bewirkt dass die truppen von assad
territoriale zugewinne erzielt haben und
hat das regime maßgeblich stabilisiert
aber seit 2012 ist eben auch der iran de
aktiv und der iran ist seit 500 jahren
der einzige staat in der nahost-region
dessen regierung und dessen
bevölkerungsmehrheit schiitisch ist in
dem die
schiitische islam staatsreligion ist im
grunde genommen ist der iran ein
sonderfall und der iran hat immer wieder
versucht seinen territorialen einfluss
in der region zu festigen und da helfen
ihm schiitische minderheiten bzw die
schiitische mehrheit im irak die dort
eben seit 2005 auch herrscht mit hilfe
der iraner und die iraner haben jetzt
fuß gefasst sie investieren bis zu sechs
milliarden us dollar pro jahr in syrien
sie haben dort eben die kaufen
ländereien berufung an die offensive
nennt liefern waffen munition sie
liefern kostenlos öl an das regime
und sie haben zusätzlich eine solche
armee aufgestellt aus circa 20.000
kritischen angeworben dann sollten sie
kommen aus afghanistan pakistan iran
irak und libanon die im dienste des
regimes von hafez al-assad kämpfe gegen
von baschar al assad gegen eben diese
politischen ort weltmacht so kompliziert
und das sagen und das ist aus sicht der
jury eine besatzung viele syrer
betrachten diese iranischen seltener
turnier-aus afghanen bestehen und
pakistan ist von überall her betrachten
diese als besatzer
denn wir haben weniger als zwei prozent
schiiten im land und wenn ich bei ihm
richtig gelesen habe exportiert dann
saudi arabien im gegenzug einen sehr
strengen islam noch ja das ist das
salafistische islam saudi arabien ist
eben ein von der wahhabitischen
konfession im sunnitischen islam
beherrscht das königreich und saudi
arabien betreibt seit den 50er jahren
eine gezielte und massive förderung
salafistischer dschihadistischer gruppen
weltweit wo dahinter noch die usa dann
stehen ja also anfänglich war deine
interessen konvergenz zwischen amerika
und saudi arabien im afghanistan krieg
gegen die sowjets dem spiel
und dann haben sich diese salafistisch
die hat ist ischen radikalen islam
gruppe neben selbstständig gemacht und
betreiben heute ihr eigenes spiel werden
aber weiterhin von saudi arabien von
einer pizza karitative organisation die
an das königshaus angegliedert sind
unterstützt aber nicht der ist und nicht
el kaida das muss noch einmal erklärt
sind saudi arabien hat formal kein
interesse an einem
von el kaida und des ersten sind ja auch
feinde saudi arabiens wir betrachten
dieses königshaus in riad als ein
vererbtes und eis immer gern sehen dass
eben diese sunnitischen rebellen
gespalten sind wir haben dann wir haben
ihm gelungen drei große gruppen wir
haben die mehr oder minder demokratisch
nationalistisch orientierten gruppen der
freien syrischen armee die mit amerika
und mit der türkei paktieren wir haben
diese unabhängigen dschihadistische
salafistischen gruppierungen die assad
stürzen wollen die von saudi arabien
finanziert werden und wir haben den s
und den ableger von al-qaida das ist
wirklich zum den überblick verlieren sie
kennen sich da wirklich sehr gut
aussehen da in die täter als rein
natürlich einem klick orientiert man
sich dann auch dort zu einem hilfe oder
waffen geliefert werden
sie haben jetzt auch eben diese
internationale verflechtung nochmal gut
geschildert nachdem wir die religiösen
komponenten gesprochen haben jetzt ganz
zum schluss unseres gesprächs wie
könnten wir denn da wieder rauskommen
sie haben immer gesagt ohne assad wird
es syrien also land nicht mehr geben
jetzt muss es aber mit aus haut gehen
nein ich habe gesagt dass man für einen
wirklichen wandel also einen start
hinter dem sich alle syrer wieder
treffen können und vereinen ob es in der
stadt also wer syrien erhalten möchte
als staat kann es nur ohne assad erhöhen
weil es braucht ja eben auch da dieses
staatsgebilde und insofern wäre es
wichtig eben die die staatsmacht auch
erstmal zu befreien von diesem assad
schon einfluss der in sämtliche
institutionen in den dienst seines
machterhalt gestellt hat aber das große
problem ist eben dass wir gar kein
gleichgewicht der kräfte haben sondern
wir haben dieses ungleichgewicht das
eben das regime mit unterstützung irans
und russland mehr oder weniger machen
kann was es möchte im land parallel dazu
ist die macht des regimes ausgehöhlt sie
haben ja so schön eingezeichnet diese
ding dunkelroten gebiete usa hat gebiete
das sind gebiete in den lokalen eliten
führen sind in den iranische sollten von
dem wir schon gehört haben die
revolutionsgarden aus dem iran die dort
das sagen haben
das heißt diese gruppen hören nicht mehr
auf den befehl aus damaskus von herrn
assad sondern die haben ihre ganz
lokalen machtstrukturen die haben
verdient an diesem krieg die am training
das ist gar nicht mehr hat das gar nicht
mehr so unter kontrolle wir uns das
vorkommen wie könnte es weitergehen also
ich bin im hinblick auf die fortführung
des krieges ziemlich pessimistisch ich
glaube der wird krieg wird noch mehrere
jahre anhalten und da wird noch sehr
viele todesopfer fordern einen
interessenausgleich zwischen den
verfeindeten lagern dh dem us lager auf
der einen seite und dem lager der
rebellen
den sehe ich nicht den sehe ich auf
absehbare zeit nicht ich sehe auch nicht
dass iran und russland jetzt ihre
einfluss potenziale die sie dort
gewonnen haben aufgeben
und ich sehe auch nicht dass syrien aus
diesem griff dieses stellvertreter
konfliktes und das ist ja ein
stellvertreter konflikt zwischen
saudiarabien der schutzmacht der
sunniten und dem schiitischen iran der
schutzmacht der schiiten herauskommt
denn es gibt keinen mechanismus bei dem
jetzt das für ethische iran mit dem
sunnitischen saudi arabien zu einem
interessenausgleich kommen kann es gibt
also nicht so etwas wie eine kommt also
eine kz de oder osze organisation im
nahen osten die durch
hintergrundgespräche bewirkt dass die
beiden seiten ihre interessen abgrenzen
und es eben zu einem interessenausgleich
kommt das ist leider nicht es ist so
komplex sie haben einblick geben in die
komplexität dieses krieges
wir haben sie auch nicht erhofft dass
sie wirklich jetzt die lösung auf den
tisch legen
ja wir schauen die zweite stunde hinein
herzlichen dank in beiden weil der
bruder dagegen wie angekündigt über gebe
jetzt an meine kollegin barbara bleisch
sie hat in genf den gebürtigen
appenzeller jakob kern getroffen
er sorgt für die uno für die verteilung
von lebensmitteln in syrien mitten im
krieg